un peu affolé tout de même joli par
l'hystérie collective les chaînes parmi
les adolescentes aux marches du palais
il y a du mal à maîtriser ce qui lui
arrive lui d'un naturel plutôt calme
il a nettement plus de succès que ce
réalisateur nommé ed wood il mémorise
jauni et ce rêveur génial qui
confectionnait des films avec quatre
sous des bouts de ficelle et des trésors
d'invention et toute l'équipe soutient
et jude law
je savais qu'il avait été surnommé le
plus mauvais réalisateur de tous les
temps scolaires et je vais interpréter
pour tim burton une fausse plus et parce
que c'était une chance de pouvoir donner
un coup de balai à cenon ce nom plein de
poussière depuis toutes ces années
pas étonnant que ce soit le réalisateur
le plus sophistiqué et le plus disjoncté
de hollywood qui réhabilite ed wood
quelquefois c'est un filtre est ténue
entre ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal
il est ressenti et on l'a tous ressenti
un moment ou un autre et surtout aimé
l'enthousiasmé de ce personnage pour les
gens de son entourage comme bela lugosi
tous ces gens merveilleux est dingue
comme bela lugosi star de l'horreur
spécialiste de dracula interprété par
martin landolt oscar du meilleur second
rôle
et pour lui ce n'était pas une mission
impossible strictes c'est presque même
de graphie je n'avais pas vu un nouveau
lien j'ai refais une action
l'or et celui là n'est pas mal dur